Okay, hopefully those NSKeyedArchiver
methods were pretty straightforward.
Time to check in and see if your
app looks something like this.
Here, I've created a few GIFS, then I
close the app, I shut it down so it's
not running in the background, and when
I relaunch it, my GIFS are still there.
Fantastic.
So, now we can check off
Persists saved GIFs.
Next up, let's go back and
set up the detail view for
the GIFs in our collection.
In order to do that, you'll need to
create the DetailViewController.
Implement our old friend,
didSelectItemAtIndexPath, to
present that detail view, and then,
add the ability to share
a GIF from that detail view.